[Music]
this is my last season as a coach on The
Voice after 23 Seasons he's so tired I
am tired of this oh yeah Blake Shelton's
friend of me Kelly Clarkson is back on
the voice and he's already sick of her
shenanigans I've got I'm nailing it it
all goes down in this first look at
season 23 with Blake pulling out all the
stops for his farewell tour I just want
everybody here to know that there's only
one king of the voice only one yeah
that's a massive sign voice fans know
he's been pointing fingers ever since
the show debuted in 2011.
I gotta go with Blake
I love beating the other coaches it's
it's what they pay me to do Kelly's the
coach with the most wins other than
Blake she has four he has nine so the
competition is real between these two
tired I am tired of this but then again
they could both lose to season 23's new
additions as Niall Horan and Chance the
Rapper take those red chairs for a first
time spin this is starting to feel like
a competition Nile is already stealing
my incredible artistic
the reason there's four coaches on The
Voice is because it takes three people
to go against me bleak's the only coach
to keep his seat on The Voice stage for
all 23 Seasons I've been doing this a
long time on this show too long some
might say and while Camila Cabello only
sat next to him for one season she does
have some advice for the guy is about to
go up against the country crooner I know
chance but I know Nile better and I just
think they're both going to be so fun
and they both have so much personality
and
are just so kind of like grounded and
have such great senses of humor so I
think it'll be fun I think it'll be
really fun to see their chemistry with
Blake too and Kelly do you think I've
got a chance of beating you in your
final season no wow strong words from a
big man how do you feel about the new
coaches Blake who are they again oh my
God Blake is not my dad no offense to my
dad there's a new kid in town it's
really just you learned so much when
you're here and you just have the
opportunity to like you know be in LA
and like work on your craft and just
like be like a sponge and at the same
time you have new eyeballs on you and
who knows it's like that it's such an
unpredictable Journey too it's like the
goal just like anything shouldn't be
just on winning because just you being
here and growing it's like you never
know what doors that's gonna open up
foreign